all right everybody focus up look
this party tonight could be a model for
the way that the world should work
and i just want to say i'm totally
stoked to the max about it
all right you guys feeling good oh yeah
oh
dennis what are you shooting video yeah
man all right well be careful with that
i might run for office someday
now trust me i think that this party can
be
the most inspirational party this campus
has ever seen is that coming to me
let me just grab that
down there
it's a gracious bug it's a righteous
belt we got going on there
we need some bodacious jock babes coming
in yeah we need some hot ass
punk rock babes i i i don't care where
they come from
the most important thing it's imperative
that we have a diversity
in the uh uh [ __ ] department
intercepted
don't sleep on barrio don't ever sleep
on barrio
that is some major dopage
apartheid is totally gnarly
it's a gnarly institution where is he
dennis that there you go come here
get this get this okay we gotta have a
system in place to get everybody weed
all right so just watch this is how
you're gonna do it all right this
this is i'm really frosty right now by
the way
this is your constitution all right it's
just a piece of paper
we gotta keep its integrity cause it's
going to hold everything together this
right here
this is us this is the american people
we're special we're magic
hello yay we all live in here all right
the most important thing
is that we don't get too far apart me
and you we got to be close that's that's
the magic of america
is love otherwise we're going to get air
bubbles in there it's going to start
canoeing and everything we don't want
that all right you get that
all right look i'm way ahead of you but
i'm already done
boom fireworks 4th of july that's for
you we want like 10 of these
oh my god i'm so fast
i'm so oh
what was i saying
you